حسم الفنان جورج وسوف الشائعات الاخبار
اللي تم تداولها مؤخرا حول اعتزاله وقال
انه راجع يغني من جديد الجدل والاخبار
انتشروا من بعد ما توفى ابن وديع في
السابع من يناير بعد عمليه جراحيه في
المعده سببت له مضاعفات النزيف ادى الى
الوفاه وكانت تمت مراسم وداع وديع جورج
وسوف في بيروت ومن بعدها تم نقل جثمانه
الى قريته يكفرون في سوريا
اللي كان مقرب جدا له ومدير اعماله وكمان
فهل راح يرجع يغني او لا والاجابه كانت
عبر بيان مكتب الفنان جورج وسوف حسن خلال
الجدل اللي صاير وخلال البيان شكر الوسوف
كل اللي وقف معه في هذه المرحله الاليمه
اللي مر فيها واعتذر عن الغاء مشاركه في
كل الحفلات والمناسبات والمهرجانات اللي
مقرره خلال الشهر هذا الشهر القادم ولفت
في البيان انه اول اغنيه راح يغنيها
الفنان من بعد هذا التوقف هي اغنيه راح
تكون لابنه الراحل وديع
[موسيقى]